[Musique]
si nous maintenons nos efforts le 19 mai
sera doux
bien une réouverture nationale des
terrasses des commerces des lieux de
culture assister à des concerts ou
regarder un match à plus de 1000
personnes
ce sera normalement possible à partir du
9 juin prochain à condition d'avoir un
pas salutaire les députés de la
commission des lois ont donné leur feu
vert hier soir une légalisation encadrée
du cannabis c'est ce que préconise un
rapport parlementaire présenté
aujourd'hui défendue par une députée de
la majorité caroline janvier ce rapport
dénonce l'inefficacité de la politique
répressive menée en france depuis des
années en fait de santander pourrait
également j'aurai des explorations
l'envers il est à un débat autour du
plateau dans la régie de bfmtv nombre
dans les personnes fumeurs de temps en
temps et cannabis ou connaissent des
personnes qui fument du cannabis mais
quelle cannabis avec cannabis qui est
issu des trafics qui est frelaté et
coupé de pneus qui coupait de différents
produits qui avec un taux de thc
extrêmement élevé ce qui est dangereux
pensez vous qu'ils trafiquants qui font
jusqu'à 60 mille 80 mille cent mille
euros d'argent liquide par semaine faut
voir une échoppe et déclaré leur argent
aux impôts et aux urssaf et rentrer chez
eux en respectant le code du travail
sortait de la naïveté
combattez la drague et ne baissez pas
les bras le tout et n'importe quoi c'est
ce qui se fait aujourd'hui avec des
consommations massive de l'insécurité
dans les quartiers
donc voilà il faut sortir il faut
essayer des méthodes nouvelles puisque
le tout répressif ne fonctionnait si
cette tribune a bénéficié d'autant de
visibilité médiatique c'est parce
qu'elle a été honteusement
instrumentalisées par madame le pen qui
ironiquement ne se complaît que dans la
division nationale et se nourrit des
tensions qui traversent notre société
madame le pen qui a voulu peut-être
envie de revivre le putsch des généraux
pour rejouer avec son bourreau nous avec
son père c'est peut-être c'est pas la
faiblesse et que vous répondiez sais que
vous êtes très mal à l'est mais je veux
terminer sur ça tout est parti d'une
déclaration le week-end dernier du
premier ministre qui a reçu d'ailleurs
une gifle qui à mon avis a eu d
résonances jusqu'à jusqu'à l'elysée je
ne vous cache pas que ça a été une bombe
qui a été posée par monsieur castex chez
les républicains
alors moi j'ai dit très clairement
renaud muselier il a posé une bombe dans
notre parti politique soit tu débranches
la monde soit appuyé sur le bouton y en
a qui a vendu social sphère febrer
ministre parce que être cocus c'est une
chose mais payer la chambre c'est pire
encore je ne veux pas de ce boulet au
pied de renaud muselier assez
insupportable donc il s'en est déjà un
boulet renaud muselier la république en
marche c est ce que renaud muselier est
un boulet la république en marche est un
boulet à au pied de renaud muselier a
déjà piégé par le premier ministre je
pense que dans son propos la vie dans la
recomposition politique
en aucun cas la région ne sera le rat de
laboratoire de la recomposition
politique n'est pas une expérience à
sion chez nous il dit que s'il sophie
cluzel démissionne eh ben elle est la
bienvenue sur ses listes donc en fait
vous n'êtes pas certain que sur le
couple où je pense qu un communiqué
clair déposition claire et reno la
journée c'est une image symbolique le
président de la république et son épouse
devant le tombeau de l'empereur
sophie cluzel se réalise j'entends bien
je sais pas quels sont les discussions
qui aujourd'hui actuellement entre les
deux têtes de liste potentielle
je sais qu'il aura à mon avis je n'ai
pas d'autre information sera des
morceaux napoléon bonaparte et une part
d'eux
parce que l'action hi les leçons du
guerrier du stratège du législateur
autant que le bâtisseur porte encore
jusqu'à notre siècle